morning many Walmart employees are
looking forward to pay raises but others
are being laid off the retail giant
announced yesterday it will increase
starting wages to $11 an hour it's
expanding maternity leave and adding
parental leave many employees are also
eligible for bonuses of up to $1,000
Walmart says more than a million hourly
workers will benefit that sounds like a
good thing but hours after announcing
the pay raises the company announced the
closing of 63 Sam's club stores up to 12
will now become fulfillment centers for
online orders Walmart did not say how
many workers will now lose their jobs
but estimates say thousands could be
affected Lea Gallagher is an editor at
Fortune magazine and joins us at the
table to discuss Lea Gallagher welcome
back good morning so two big
announcements here yesterday is a timing
important here the timing is it was
confusing to a lot of people because
they were just to sort of opposite
announcements and you know many PR
experts might say you do the bad news
first and then you do the good news but
you know there were two big pieces of
news as well from the number one company
on the fortune 500 so it was a lot to
digest so it sounded good at first but
then you hear about the layoffs do they
can feather out well they're two very
different stories I mean the the first
news the news that Walmart is raising
minimum wage it's part of a bigger
transformation Walmart has been
undergoing under the new not-so-new as
of 2004 CEO Doug McMillon it's raised it
from nine to ten ten and then and now 10
to 11 so this is a you know it's really
rethinking how it treats its employees
and the benefits are significant
including benefits for adoption for the
first time and increasing the belief so
that's all good you know yes it's pegged
to this tax plan as so many other
companies has come out and said we are
going to you know give everyone more
money this is wonderful
but you know it's it is a little bit
bigger than that and then the closings
are another story Sam's Club which is
the company's warehouse division or
membership club retailer division has
been struggling for a while now it has
been losing ground to Costco and look
retail is really tough right now this
company is in retail warfare and so that
is part of what's happening there which
is separate the other problems that tax
bill is that it would create jobs so on
that front
not happening what Walmart's a big
employer how does this affect it does it
affect other employers well walmart sort
of sets the tone in terms of what it
does with its wages and and not so long
ago it was not doing these things with
wages so this does send a message and
again I think also on the benefits side
of things it's not just about wages and
the other argument there though is we're
in a very tight labor market now so all
companies are under pressure to raise
wages simply from a competitive
standpoint but Walmart is the number one
private company employer two point three
million employees of 1.5 million in the
US alone and this for that reason is is
significant Walmart says they hope to
place some of these employees at the
Sam's Club at other stores what's the
likelihood that that could happen
that could happen I mean it is such a
big company it could absorb those
employees the other thing that's
happening is it's taking I think about
ten maybe up to twelve of those Sam's
Clubs and repurposing them as
distribution fulfillment centers for
e-commerce which is what's happening
retailers are in this position now they
have all this real estate and people are
buying online they're trying desperately
to really make it possible for you to
get your products as fast as you can and
fulfillment centers are a big part of
the puzzle there so those fulfillment
centers will obviously need employees so
it's unclear how many people will be
impacted by the Sam's Club news the gala
girl always good to have you here thank
you so much great to be here